For over two decades now, if the New York
news (or any other present) needs a soundbite
or quote from an “everyman” or “man
on the street” to round off a story, there
has been one man they’ve been able to rely
on with an almost staggering level of consistency-
Gregory Packer.
Since the mid-1990s, Packer has been quoted
hundreds of times by newspapers across America
and has aired his opinions on everything from
the Iraq War to the Star Wars movies.
A divisive figure among media members, Packer
has been both praised and mocked for his stalwart
dedication to being the first to show up to
newsworthy events, whether the media likes
it or not.
Born in 1963 in Huntington, New York, profiles
of Packer in the very newspapers he’s been
so frequently quoted note that he harbored
a fascination with celebrity from a very young
age, starting at age 8 when Packer’s mother
gave him a signed photo of Natalie Wood, reportedly
after she met the actress by chance on a plane.
Four years later, Packer’s father stoked
the fires of his son’s obsession by gifting
him an autograph from boxing legend Joe Louis.
As he entered his formative years, Packer
took to seeking out celebrities on his own,
tracking down his favourite hockey players
for autographs after games or public appearances.
Little is known about Packer’s life directly
after he graduated high school in 1983, save
for the fact that he got a job working as
a highway maintenance worker sometime in the
late 1980s- a job that he somehow retired
from in the early 2000s while only in his
late 30s.
Since then, Packer has stepped up his life’s
mission to be quoted by as many news sources
as possible by making it a full-time gig…
Why?
It all started in 1995, when he was quoted
by the Tampa Tribune as saying: “The Jewish
people are fans of Pope John Paul II.”
Packer notes that seeing his name in print
made him feel like he’d “accomplished
something”.
He further states, “Sometimes I need to
stick my face in a camera.
I just need to show people I’m alive….
I really am totally obsessed with having my
name out there, but it’s a healthy obsession.
It’s not like I’m hurting anyone.”
In an attempt to recapture that high he found
when his words appeared in the Tampa Tribune,
he states he began attending roughly two major
events every week, using his weekends, vacation,
and personal days to accomplish this.
When the latter ran out, Packer would sometimes
just call in sick, missing pay for that day,
but at least potentially getting his name
in the news.
When asked in 2002 if he was worried that
calling in sick to wait in line to buy tickets
to a Britney Spears concert might get him
fired, Packer responded frankly: “Even if
when I went back to work I got fired, I know
I would have the full support of the public.”
Since his early retirement, he has, however,
not had any such work issue and has been able
to be the first in line for almost every major
event in New York State, and occasionally
branching out to places across the country
when possible, attending book signings, political
rallies, concerts, parades, sporting events,
mall openings, product releases, and even
funerals, such as attempting to go to Whitney
Houston’s funeral.
(Only those invited actually got to see the
funeral, but the fact that he essentially
camped out as close to the action as was allowed,
he still got his quote in the news, stating
“It’s important to be out here with the
fans…
They should have allowed everyone to see it.”)
The result of all of this is that Packer has
been quoted by nearly every major newspaper
and news organisation in the United States.
He’s also briefly met at least three different
U.S. presidents (Bill Clinton, Jimmy Carter,
George W. Bush- who he had a nice conversation
about baseball with; he claims he’s actually
met four presidents, but doesn’t appear
to mention anywhere who the fourth one was).
On top of that, he’s watched Michael Jackson
do the moonwalk up close and personal, met
Dennis Rodman, Britney Spears, Courtney Love,
Mariah Carey, Garth Brooks, Ringo Starr, sat
in the front row at the Super Bowl twice,
was one of the first people in America to
buy an iPhone (waiting in line 110 straight
hours to do it), and had none other than Hillary
Clinton seemingly recognize him on-sight,
surprising Packer at a book signing by saying,
“Hello, Mr. Packer”.
He accomplished all of this thanks, in part,
to his apparent superpower- the ability to
ignore fatigue and boredom for countless hours
on end while appearing extremely jovial the
entire time.
You see, as you might have guessed based on
what you’ve read so far, Packer quickly
discovered that the best way to be quoted
by the press, meet some celebrity, or appear
on TV was simply to be the first person in
line for a major event; once that’s accomplished,
to increase odds even further, he states you
must be continually boisterously happy and
friendly while sitting there and waiting-
sometimes for days.
In all cases, Packer waits with the simple
hope that he’ll be approached by a reporter
or otherwise just appear on TV in some way,
with the latter often happening in wide pan
shots of the line and event, or sometimes
with Packer appearing in the background, such
as times when a famous person is addressing
the media or giving a speech where a crowd
is allowed around.
As such, it should come as no surprise that
Packer has been described by some as a “professional
line sitter”, impressively usually seen
pictured waiting in line with little more
than a newspaper and wearing simple, everyman
outfits that fit the event, including things
like Yankees shirts or NYPD hoodies.
Packer rarely brings either food or water
to events unless absolutely necessary, such
as when camping out for days, once being quoted
as saying, “I don’t bring extra supplies
because you’ve got to worry about supplies
being left behind.”
Naturally, his frequency of being at all these
events and so often getting quoted was bound
to eventually become noticed within the world
of journalism, and there has been some backlash
to his striving to achieve his simple dream.
On that note, Packer has had an uneasy relationship
with the public at large, with some applauding
his commitment and tenacity, while others
openly deride his apparent obsession with
his own notoriety.
In regards to the latter, a writer for Business
Insider covering the story of Packer being
the first in line to buy an iPad even went
so far as calling him:
The same stupid guy who’s first in line
for everything.
A sentiment echoed by many in the media, in
particular the Associated Press, who, in 2003,
strongly discouraged reporters from speaking
to him after higher ups noticed he’d been
quoted in at least 100 publications up to
that point.
As such, they issued a memo stating,
The world is full of all kinds of interesting
people.
One of them is Greg Packer of Huntington,
NY, who apparently lives to get his name on
the AP wire and in other media….
Mr Packer is clearly eager to be quoted.
Let’s be eager, too- to find other people
to quote.
As to this, Packer stated he thinks this memo
just might end up being the biggest highlight
of his career.
That said, in a mini-documentary about his
life as a “man on the street”, Packer
expressed that he feels bad knowing reporters
can get in trouble for quoting him, but argues
that there’s nothing inherently wrong with
him simply being in the “right place at
the right time” to offer a timely, often
innocuous quote or soundbite.
The fact that he goes out of his way to ensure
that this is the case and has admitted to
“making stuff up to get in the paper”
in the past doesn’t appear to bother Packer
all that much; he feels that he is doing reporters
a favor by helping them get their job done
quicker, and tailoring his quotes in such
a way to make their life easier.
In fact, to our knowledge, the only time Packer
has refused to give a quote was during an
interview with the New York Times in 2003.
When asked by reporter Alan Feuer for his
opinion on recent scandals in the world of
journalism, Packer, who has a deep respect
for journalists, simply responded “I have
no comment”.
In the end, while some have taken a somewhat
negative attitude when it comes to Packer’s
obsession with appearing in the media, there
is something to be admired in a person who
derives such pleasure from something so simple.
While most dream pie in the sky things- becoming
a famous and wildly successful actor, musician,
artist, businessman, etc., Packer has chosen
another path, having only a small dream, which
he pursues with vigor, unlike most who dream
bigger but do nothing about it.
He just wants to get his name in print or
face on TV, and admirably pursues this in
completely benign ways, hurting no one in
the process, nor instigating any negative
drama.
As a professor of pop culture at Syracuse
University, Robert Thompson, stated,
This guy has clearly found something he loves
to do, and few people have done that.
You have to admire that.
How many people have found something that
they love to wake up at 2:30 in the morning
to do?
Not very many.
Or to quote the man himself in an interview
from 2002: “This is what I like doing.
You only live once, you might as well make
the most of it.”